métro boulot mais pas dodo pour edouard
balladur ce matin toulouse en compagnie
du maire dominique baudis le premier
ministre a officiellement inauguré la
première ligne du métro toulousain un
val entièrement automatique
construit par matra comme à lille ou
marseille une ligne de 10 km qui
permettra de traverser toulouse en 17
minutes
d'où l'expression à la mode dans la cité
des violettes il est beau dit le métro
reportage sandrine merck et dominique
tripiers il attendait depuis dix ans
leur métro à toulouse à 13 heures
tapantes le val véhicule automatique
léger leur a enfin ouvert les bras
c'est la ruée l'entousiasme ses joueurs
pour le bac il le fallait à toulouse est
vraiment un type formidable c'est génial
ça va désengorger la ville
pari tenu monsieur le maire élu sur sa
campagne pour le métro en 83 après avoir
férocement batailler contre le tramway
dominique baudis ouvre aujourd'hui la
ligne en compagnie du premier ministre
je partage la joie et le bonheur des
toulousains je crois que quand une ville
sera d'une grande ambition a un grand
projet ça lui donne de la force et de
l'énergie et puis aujourd'hui les gens
sont heureux on le voit c'est vraiment
du tout l'air d'avoir l'autonomie pour
venir le de jolis moments ici j'aurais
jamais cru que convient le maire
voitures ont déjà foutu d'une heure pour
venir la vie mais carrément rendu
inaccessible aux personnes handicapées
enfin enfin un transport en commun
accessible 18 minutes pour traverser
toulouse la banlieue reconnecter au
centre ville 15 stations et autant
d'oeuvres d'art pour les mamies cure
toulouse c'est le saut dans l'an 2000 on
était content d'elvis items et moi je
sais pas s'ils répondent souvent un
repère pour les ramasser ça m'évite de
s'allier ce n'est qu'après deux ans
six amis aller au métro et
on a moins chaud que j'ai menée tôt afin
dé moby le métro a coûté 3,3 milliards
de francs pour le ticket ce sera 7
francs